ich dachte der 35.000 euro koffer wird
heuer 43.000 euro so ein hässliches
stück scheiße allem ein name ist luca
meine damen und herren ihr könnt euch
wahrscheinlich noch an das video von mir
vor einigen wochen erinnern wo ich mir
das teuerste produkt auf der website von
gucci angesehen habe
also das hier ist nun also das teuerste
herrenbekleidung produkt zu bei gucci in
dem video habe ich gesagt wenn ihr
100000 like schafft dann bestelle ich
mir dieses produkt probiere es an und
zeige es euch und das habt ihr dann auch
geschafft die jacke war echt ziemlich
hässlich auf jeden fall seht ihr es ja
bereits im titel eingeblendet ich muss
gar nicht mehr lange und heißen brei
herum reden meine damen und herren ich
mache heute einen zweiten teil auf der
website
oh mein gott da ist noch immer silvester
bei den hauptsache sind so palmen und
unter den palmen liegen geschenke in der
wüste während eines feuerwerks einfach
mal sommer winter weihnachten und
silvester kombiniert wir befinden uns
hier auf jeden fall auf der website von
louis vitton ganz kurz falls die louis
vitton nicht kennt dann wohnt ihr glaube
ich hinterm berg louie vito ist eine
marke von der ich wirklich nie etwas
kaufen würde
stand jetzt finde ich jedes produkt
fahrt hässlich deswegen ist dieses video
hier für mich umso schlimmer zu machen
denn ich muss mir nachher wahrscheinlich
etwas bestellen beziehungsweise ihr
dürft wieder entscheiden also bleibt auf
jeden fall bis zum ende des videos dran
ihr dürft diesmal vor allem auch
entscheiden welches produkt ich bestelle
also wir bekommen eine auswahl aber wir
schauen uns erst mal die produkte
anpassen wird of travel horizon hier
sitzt jemand in einem helikopter und
fliegt über paris gerade da ist ein
video hier ist auch noch mal ein video
das will ich alles gar nicht sehen das
sind alles bilder aus new york das hier
ist ein interview mit dem designer der
es gibt eine louis vuitton app menschen
nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßen hier
können wir uns dann den koffer in 360
grad anschauen also dass ich eben seine
meinung aber das ist doch wirklich
einfach nicht schön also ich kann schon
verstehen wir dass ältere leute eher
mögen ja doch der ist schön
dann muss ich sagen der sind wirklich
cool aus der sie auch die sonne
roth dose aber gut wir gehen mal weiter
runter hier haben jetzt die 3
das 1 2650 cheeseburger aber
sind doch somit die teuersten pro die
protoss ist noch teurer fast 3000 euro
wie überdimensionale prognose geben wir
weiter runter das hier sind jetzt nicht
mehr so teure sachen also im vergleich
zu 2009 100 geht das 3001
ich komme ich nach hause und jetzt auf
sticker drauf vor dem kind also gut dass
wir sind auf jeden fall die koffer ist
das teuerste produkt 3150 okay das
schreibe ich mir mal auf nächtlicher
koffer 3150 euro ok hab ich jetzt
aufgeschrieben allerdings sind wir ja
nicht hier für die koffer sondern auch
für die herren sachen das heißt wir
schauen jetzt erstmal bei allen herren
taschen vorbei da werden wahrscheinlich
koche auch 1600 in ordnung bei der gucci
website war es möglich dass man sich das
ganze den preis nach oben also von
tieren haben lassen kann tun
hier ist das ganze nicht möglich das
heißt wir müssen jetzt einfach mal
durchgehen 3100 der koffer kostet 50
euro mehr
das heißt ein rucksack wird es heute
wahrscheinlich nicht für mich seine frau
wieder 3000 vereine aktien
ich dachte aktien tasche eine
aktentasche für 3100 euro okay gut wer's
braucht alles klar kannst du dir gern
kaufen ich brauche es nicht immer weiter
lang die preise das ist aber wir müssen
mal ganz kurz festhalten dass die sachen
echt hardcore hässlich sind wer wird
sich so ein rucksack aufsetzen das sieht
aus wie minecraft wright aus 400
egal das sieht aus wie so eine billige
amazon kameratasche als bestandteil der
frühjahr sommer 2009 10 prequel welche
sich um weltraumreisen dreht jeder
astronaut hat seinen rucksack mit dem
weltraum mischer weltraum als rucksack
3400 euro habe ich jetzt auch notiert
aber vielleicht haben wir sogar noch
einen teureren rucksack hier die sachen
sehen allerdings alle ein bisschen
günstiger aus also das heißt günstig
2500 euro sind da mittlerweile schon
günstig auf der website 2800 haben wir
hier noch wenn wir weiter runter gehen
2500 2400 dann wieder aktentaschen hier
[Musik]
waren sie da diesem video 15.000 mein
wachen kopf hat schon ein produkt ja die
wollte ich mir auf jeden fall bestehen
ehe christopher p eben zaubert den
wilden geist eines wanderrucksack auf
monogram canvas und mathis krokodilleder
er ist für die arbeit und in der
freizeit perfekt und steht für einen
eleganten lifestyle
für mich steht er nur für scheiße
scheiße rucksack 15.600 euro ein paar
sekunden später
es ist ich war ich sehe gerade einen
rucksack für 15.000 euro ich grolle ein
produkt weiter und wer 38.000 europa
eine aktentasche dieser strauß kostet 5
euro geht finde ich schöner als das die
leute real rap alben ich hab nichts
gegen leute die sich so was kaufen oder
die sogar schön
die gleiche tasche
in noch hässlicher wir sind hier jetzt
auch durch damit die letzte tasche
wieder so eine minecraft tasche also
meine damen und herren das teuerste
produkt gerade sind 38.000 euro
ich bin gespannt was meine kreditkarte
dazu sagt wir gehen jetzt mal auf ready
to wear alle kollektionen also das sind
so jacken sache nicht
no shit
die akustik wie finde ich aber ehrlich
gesagt ganz neues
die school
ehrlich
100 euro kosten würde würde ich die
holen gibt auch neues
im ernst also beschützen sind die sachen
jetzt auch nicht ja noch eine jacke für
4500 euro dann gehe ich hier 4100 euro
690 890 2100 dann haben wir hier noch
2100 auch wieder
hazy bisschen aus wie draco malfoy jetzt
wieder so komplett hässliche kleidung
mit dabei ich denke aber wenn ich ganz
ehrlich wir werden nicht über den 38.000
euro koffer kommen
ich kann den gar nicht kaufen also ich
hab so viel geld auf ein konto ohne
angeben zu wollen also ich würd das
hinkriegen den zu kaufen und zu
bestellen und ich würde ja dann auch
wieder zurücksenden aber ich habe also
jeder mensch hat ja ein limit bei seiner
karte
um eine kreditkarte da ist noch ein
limit von 6000 euro 5970 dass von den
vier produkte nicht ausgesucht habe kann
ich nur zwei bestellen
das ist sehr hässliche koffer vom beginn
und der komische weltraum alpha rucksack
ich fans aber ehrlich gesagt auch echt
dumm wenn ich mir jetzt ein koffer
bestellen würde weil es geht ja
eigentlich um ein produkt das man
anzieht das heißt aus den kategorien
hier würde eigentlich alles raus fallen
von wegen herren taschen kleinlederwaren
dürfte accessoires uhren schmuck und
reisegepäck die einzigen kategorien von
ihm etwas bestellen würde wäre ready to
wear und schuhe schuhe können wir mal
schauen welches label
da ist ein weiß es nicht der kostet 720
euro
der run away sneaker der heißt so den
gleichen schuhe gibt es in schwarz
der kostet der 6900 euro
der run away sneaker exakt der gleiche
ist nicht meine lieben louis vitton
kunden ja uns gedacht der schulen weiß
so gut ankamen haben wir euch den jetzt
auch mal ins schwarze den shop für 6200
euro mehr kaufen wollt dann macht es
doch mal
also das ist ja echt der absolute
wahnsinn was die sich rausnehmen also
das ist wirklich da fragt man sich nicht
warum der typ der 430 mensch der welt
ist die davor weiße dem bill gates und
der typ der amazon erfunden hat und so
weiter und so fort der jf und dann kommt
einer der einfach nur über teure
kleidung macht hässliche überteuerte
kleidung wie bereits gesagt ich will
hier überhaupt nicht hetzen gegen ihn
oder gegen die ganzen produkte es ist
geschmackssache aber laut meinem
geschmack ist das scheiße was ist das
das sieht aus wie ein halber
bowlingschuhe also wer's mag kann sowas
ja gern tragen dass sie sind die
einzigen die ich eigentlich ganz cool
finde aber ich glaube louis vitton will
auch gar nicht dass solche leute wie ich
das cool finden sondern er halt ältere
leute mit einer höheren
zahlungsbereitschaft aber meine damen
und herrn wir müssen jetzt genau auf den
punkt kommen bei dem heutigen video im
der sneaker die nicht gerade ausgesucht
hatte 6100 kann ich mir nicht leisten
mit meinem kreditkarten saldo dingsbums
gerade die bestellen das teuerste
produkt zum anziehen bis 5.950 euro 5970
euro die 20 euro unterschied würde ich
da wahrscheinlich ein zahnstocher
bekommen ich bin aber auch ganz ehrlich
ich fänd schuhe auch ein bisschen
langweilig finde kleidung eigentlich ein
bisschen interessanter das heißt wir
genau mal hier in alle kollektionen und
schauen uns hier jetzt noch mal oben wie
gesagt die jacke finde ich mega geil
aber es geht ja nicht darum dass ich
etwas bestelle was ich geil findet
sondern wirklich etwas bestelle was
teuer ist das halt 4500 euro hier haben
wir eine coach jacke mit louis vitton
satellite aufnäher die kostet 1100 die
packe ich auch mal einen neuen tab rein
dann haben wir hier unten noch als es
müssten lediglich so sachen seien diese
4000 5000 euro kosten wir haben eine
3900 euro lederjacke
dann gehen wir weiter durch die meisten
sachen hier sind wirklich unter 1000
euro muss sich wirklich mal klatschen
ich hätte wirklich nicht gedacht dass
louis vitton nochmal sonnen krasse
stückchen teurer ist als gucci
4200 euro nur wenige minuten später
ich dachte der 35.000 euro koffer wird
heuer 43.000 euro so ein hässliches
stück scheiße
also
das ist ja ganz armes deutschland es ist
das ende
900 ich glaube wir haben eine auswahl
freunde diese jacke kost 4500 diese hier
schon mal günstiger 4100 dies auch
günstiger auch günstiger kommt auch beck
dies auf günstiger kommt auch wenn dies
teurer und dies teurer also freunde die
drei sachen stehen zur auswahl quillt
sit down blau sortiert und irreversible
aviator jacket ihr findet jetzt eine
umfrage da könnt ihr sagen welches mich
mir bestellen soll ich bestelle dieses
produkt allerdings erst wenn ihr 100000
likes bei diesem video geschafft habt
aber ich bin ganz ehrlich meine damen
und herren ich war letzte woche bei der
bank und musste mir von meinem
bankberater anhören lassen ja also
finanzierungs technisch gesehen das ist
jetzt auch nicht so klug wenn du dir für
6000 euro nokia gekauft das war ein
bisschen unangenehm ist gespräch
deswegen 300.000 likes bin ich gerne
dazu bereit das zu bestellen und von
meiner bank anrufe anzunehmen und wieder
gespräche mit denen zu haben aber alle
meine damen und herren entscheiden
100000 leicht sie finden hier oben wie
gesagt umfrage eingeblendet wenn ihr auf
dieses klick da ist diese umfrage da
könnt ihr sagen welches politische
stellen sondern dann sehen wir uns
eventuell in ein zwei wochen wieder wenn
ihr die likes geknackt habt ich mit
meiner bank gesprochen habe ich dieses
produkt bestellt habe und dann probiere
ich das produkt an
ich habe jetzt schon keinen bock drauf
[Musik]